لقد تحطمت شجاعتهم وتوسلوا
لمعرفة مصيرهم ، هذا
ما حدث لمقاتلي داعش البريطانيين المشهورين على نطاق واسع
والمعروفين باسم البيتلز في
الأسر في سوريا ، أعتقد أن دوري في
هذا السيناريو برمته هذه الحلقة
بأكملها كان أحد أخطائي يموت ،
نعم  أود أن أعتذر عن ذلك ،
هل ترغب في الاعتذار لكل شخص
متورط مع كل شخص تأثر
بشكل مباشر أو غير مباشر أنهم
متهمون بالتعذيب في شبكة زنازين داعش التابعة لداعش ،
وهو ما ينفونه ، لكنهم الآن
يقدمون اعترافًا نادرًا حاولوا
ترتيب فدية للبعض  من
رهائن داعش الأوروبيين ، كان مقاتلًا
يستخرج منهم عناوين البريد الإلكتروني
للاتصالات إذا كان ذلك دليلًا على الحياة
يسألون شيئًا كانوا هم فقط
سيكونون قادرين على الإجابة عن سبب
موافقتك على هذا الدور ، لقد
حدث بنفس الطريقة  ما شرحه الإسكندر للتو في
البداية مجرد تأمل
بين السجناء الأجانب والأشخاص الذين
يتعاملون مع عملية التفاوض
مع عائلاتهم  لمحاولة الحصول على
فدية ، نعم ، نعم ، يعترف كوت
بالمساعدة عن بُعد من سوريا في الحصول على
سلاح ناري لمؤامرة اغتيال داعش
التي فشلت في لندن في عام 2016 ، وهو ما
فعله بعد ذلك ، ولم أكن متورطًا
في أن الخضر لديهم عندما  التقيت
بهم منذ عام مضى شخصيًا لقد ولت منذ فترة طويلة
، وربما أفتقد السمك ورقائق البطاطس المحظوظين
الآن ، وقد هُزِمَت داعش ، التي يُطلق عليها اسم الخلافة ،
هناك اثنان من آلاف
سجناء داعش المحتجزين في شمال سوريا والذين
لا يعرفون ماذا سيحدث لهم
لا تريد المملكة المتحدة عودتهم ، لذا
سيبقون هنا أو يواجهون عقوبة الإعدام في
العراق أو على الأرجح في الولايات المتحدة.
لا أفهم سبب قيامك بذلك
الآن ، هل تحاول تجنب إرسالك
إلى الولايات المتحدة
أي شيء أعتقد أن هذا الاعتراف
ربما يعجل تسليمنا أو
تسليمنا إلى الولايات المتحدة ، لا
أعتقد أن هذا شيء
سيمنعني من الذهاب إلى الولايات
المتحدة على الإطلاق. لا أرى كيف يمكن
أن يكون ذلك ممكنًا.  تعرف إلى أين
يذهب هذا  من هنا فصاعدًا ، أعلم
فقط أنني أريد أن تنتهي هذه الفترة من هذا الجزء
، وأنا أعلم أن هذا هو
ما يجب القيام به ، والحقيقة يجب أن
تخرج من إيزيس ، أعدمت رهائن أجانب بشكل
رهيب ومع ذلك يصر الزوجان على
أنهما لم يكن لهما دور  في جرائم القتل أو
التعذيب هذه ، قال العديد من الرهائن
السابقين إنهم تعرضوا للتعذيب على أيدي
رجال بلكنات بريطانية تتطابق مع
مظهرهم ، وقد تم
تحديد مصير عشرات السجناء الفرنسيين الذين
شوهد بعضهم هنا في
مقاطع الفيديو الدعائية القديمة
لداعش بسرعة في الأسابيع الماضية التي تم إرسالها من
شمال سوريا إلى  العراق هناك
حكم قاضٍ عراقي عليهم بالإعدام
شنقًا بعد 10 دقائق فقط من
المداولات والتمثيل من قبل
المحامين الذين لم يلتق بهم الكثيرون قبل
المحاكمة ردًا على مزاعم القوات الأمريكية
بترتيب النقل
قال متحدث باسم التحالف إن القوات الأمريكية
احتجزت عددًا صغيرًا.  من
مقاتلي داعش من القوات الديمقراطية السورية
لنقلهم إلى حكومة
العراق لكنه لم يقدم أي تفاصيل
يشتبه بداعش الأمريكية  مثل سامانثا الحسن الثاني
قد أعيدوا إلى الولايات المتحدة لمحاكمتهم
ولكن لمن تركوا وراءهم مصيرهم
غير واضح أو ربما مع الجلاد العراقي يكونون
بمثابة رادع أو علامة
لا تريد بعض الدول
إنهاء مهمة إحضارهم إلى  العدالة
[موسيقى]